I'll start with the small layout.
At min-width 450 pixels, the only
real change from the default, is that
the light blue and the green elements
both take up 50% of the viewport.
So, at min-width 450 pixels,
I set width 50% for
the light blue and the green elements.
So far, so good.
At min-width 550 pixels,
it looks like the only difference is
that now the red box only takes up 40%
of view port, while the orange box,
takes up 60% of the view port.
So, I made my change,
and well to be honest,
this doesn't quite look
like what I expected.
I thought the red box would be
probably a little bit farther over.
So you know what, let's go ahead and
change something.
Inside Dev Tools, I'll change that 40%,
which I was mistaken about.
And I'll change that to 33%,
which means that the width of
the orange box needs to be 66.6%.
I was a little bold there and instead
of testing first, I just went ahead and
set the widths inside my source code,
but looking at this height,
this isn't actually what I expected.
I think the orange isn't
taking up enough space, and
I think the red is taking
up too much space.
So, I think I'll use devtools
to make some adjustments.
Instead of 40 60, I'll go ahead and
make it one-third and two-thirds.
So, red becomes 33.3%,
and orange becomes 66.6%.
All right, that's looking a lot better.
And lastly, there's min-width,
800 pixels.
The only difference between 550 and
800 pixels, is that with 800 pixels,
there are now left and right margins.
At the break point with
the min-width of 800 pixels.
I went ahead and
set a fixed width of 800 pixels and
then a margin left and
margin right of auto.
With a quick save and
a refresh of the browser,
it looks like the page now has
margins on the left and right.
Already, that looks pretty good.